Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P.
This may be my favorite story about
one of our newest viewers, an 81 year
old Canadian grandmother. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Longtime listener.
So I just wanted to tell you a funny
story. My 81 year old grandmother who
found you on Facebook. I recently found
out that she watches you every day. So
you can put that in the bank. Up here in Canada. I
love that. Additionally, I just wanted to mention
that I really appreciate your slight comical
nuances that you have on the show. I really
appreciate that because life and politics can
get so serious very quickly. So I appreciate
having a laugh every day when I watch your show.
Speaker 1: Well, I really appreciate that. And
say hello to grandma for me. I absolutely love
that. We have a great bonus show for you today.
The Stop the Steal people are training so-called
poll observers to wreak complete havoc in November
at polls around the country. Dennis Prager says
that there is no secular argument against incest.
Were it not for religion, everybody would be. I
guess having sex with their sister sounds weird.
And then Tulsi Gabbard is immediately
jumping into campaigning for a Republican.
She's now an independent. She left the
Democratic Party, but she's not a right
wing nut, but she's immediately campaigning
for a Republican. Okay. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. Don't
miss it. Sign up. It joined backup.